[Hamza] Kiki!
[Kiki] Ja?
[Hamza] Willst du einen Pinguin?
[Kiki] Einen was?
[Hamza] Pingui!
[Kiki] Ja, bring mal mit!
[Kiki] Hamza, das heißt Pingui, nicht Pinguin!
[Hamza] Nein, das heißt Pinguin!
[Kiki] Doch, Pingui! Das ist der Markenname!
[Hamza] Das heißt ja auch nicht "Mau", das heißt "Maus", oder?
[Kiki] *genervtes Seufzen*
[Hamza] Wie isst du deinen Pinguin?
[Kiki] Hm?
[Hamza] Wieso isst du das so?
[Kiki] Ganz normal!
[Hamza] Hä? Das ist nicht normal!
[Kiki] Ja, ganz normal! Wie isst du denn dein Pingui?
[Kiki] Hä? Ich weiß gar nicht, was dein Problem ist!
[Kiki] Weißt du was? Wir rufen jetzt beim Bundesverband für Süßigkeitenverzehrempfehlungen an!
[Kiki] Ich hab die Nummer sogar gespeichert!
[Hamza] Sowas gibt's doch gar nicht!
[Kiki] Doch!
[Hamza] Ja dann ruf doch an!
[Kiki] Wir rufen da jetzt an und dann fragen wir!
Guten Tag und herzlich willkommen beim Kundenservice des Bundesverbands für Süßigkeitenverzehrempfehlungen.
Bitte wählen Sie eines der folgenden Optionen:
Für Kinder Maxi King wählen Sie die 1.
Für Kinder Pingui wählen Sie die 2.
Für Kinder Bueno wählen Sie die 3.
Für Milchschnitte wählen Sie die 4.
[Kiki] Zwei!
Okay, Kinder Pingui!
Unsere Verzehrempfehlung eines Kinder Pinguis gestaltet sich wie folgt:
Knabbern Sie behutsam die Schokoladenhülle ab.
Entfernen Sie nun die Creme.
Wählen Sie dafür wahlweise Ihre Zunge oder Ihren rechten Zeigefinger.
Verzehren Sie anschließend den Zartbitterkern.
Nun dürfen Sie den Rest des Riegels abbeißen.
Wenn Sie ins Hauptmenü gelangen möchten, drücken Sie die Rautetaste.
Falls Sie keine weiteren Fragen haben, legen Sie einfach auf.
Vielen Dank für Ihren Anruf!
[Kiki] Hab ich dir doch gesagt!
[Hamza] Du hattest recht!
[Kiki] Und jetzt mach ich ein Kinder Pingui in XXL!
[Hamza] Aber sowas von!
Hi zusammen!
Heute gibt's ein neues XXL Rezept, das gab es echt verdammt lange nicht mehr!
Warum eigentlich Hamza?
[Hamza] Ich glaub wir haben's vergessen!
Keine Ahnung! Eigentlich sind wir bekannt für unsere XXL Rezepte!
Wir hatten schon Toffifee, Raffaello, Bueno..
[Hamza] Die auch geschmeckt haben, ne?
[Kiki] Klar!
Und Knoppers-Nussriegel als der ganz neu rauskam!
Und jetzt hab ich mir gedacht: "Jeder liebt Kinder Pingui, jeder!"
Wenn es einen von euch gibt, der nicht Kinder Pingui liebt, schreibt's mir in die Kommentare!
[Kiki] Das - das glaube ich einfach nicht!
[Hamza] M-hm!
Ich fang jetzt direkt an mit dem Biskuitboden, ich schreibe euch -
[Hamza] An der Stelle: Das ist auch keine Werbung!
Das ist keine Werbung! Natürlich ist es irgendwo Werbung aber keine bezahlte Werbung meinst du wohl!
Wir machen jetzt zuallererst den Schokobiskuitboden.
Macht euch keine Sorgen: Alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen unten in der Videobeschreibung
und ich zeige es euch so Schritt für Schritt, dass jeder das nachmachen kann. Selbst wenn ihr Backanfänger seid!
Ich geb jetzt zuallererst in meine Küchenmaschine
- ihr könnt auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden -
da gebe ich zuallererst Eier rein.
Dann eine Prise Salz... da war ich jetzt unvorbereitet! *lacht*
Prise Salz, die hebt nochmal den süßen Geschmack.
Da gebe ich Zucker mit dazu und dann wird das ungefähr - also richtig lange, ungefähr 8min lang
auf höchster Geschwindigkeit richtig schön dick-cremig geschlagen.
So, als nächstes sieben wir alle trockenen Zutaten dazu und rühren das nochmal ganz kurz ein.
Wichtig ist, dass es wirklich nur solange untergerührt wird, bis es sich gerade so verbunden hat,
sonst geht nämlich die ganze schöne Luft wieder raus und die Eiermasse ist richtig schön fluffig gerade!
[Hamza] Also Leute: Haltet euch bitte ans Rezept!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Auch nicht austauschen irgendwas! Kauft genau das ein, was Kiki euch sagt!
[Kiki] Genau, dann gelingt's euch 100%ig!
[Hamza] Es gibt ja Leute, die sagen: "Kann ich das ersetzen?", "Oh, ich hab das so gemacht, ich hab das so gemacht!"
[Kiki] Ja! Grad bei so einem XXL-Rezept, wo's generell alles ein bisschen instabil ist. Aber macht euch keine Sorgen, mein XXL Kinder Pingui wird muy buen sein!
[Hamza] Bueno! *lacht*
Ruck-zuck ist der Teig auch schon fertig, das ging jetzt echt schnell!
Also die meiste Arbeit hat ja die Maschine übernommen.
Und im nächsten Schritt packe ich jetzt den Teig in meinen Backrahmen.
Oh, das war sehr unelegant! "Packt ich jetzt den Teig"!
[Kiki] Auf jeden Fall wird der Teig jetzt gebacken.
[Hamza] Wie soll man denn sonst sowas sagen?
Reingeben! Den Backrahmen hab ich eingestellt auf 30x37cm
auch weil ich einen geraden Abschluss habe. Ihr könntet das auch sonst im normalen Backblech backen.
Dann verändert sich aber vielleicht auch die Backzeit!
Ich werde ihn jetzt hier reingeben und dann bei 190°C Ober- und Unterhitze für 12-14min backen
und dann zugedeckt vollständig auskühlen lassen.
So, während der Teig jetzt im Ofen backt, mach ich schon mal die Creme und die ist SO easy Leute!
SO easy!
Wir geben jetzt alles in die Küchenmaschine. Es gibt nur eine Bedingung: Alles muss kalt sein!
Sahne kalt, Mascarpone kalt, Schüssel und Schneebesenaufsatz kalt!
Und wenn das erledigt ist, dann ist alles...
[Kiki] Sag doch auch mal was!
[Kiki] Einfach!
[Hamza] Du hast den Faden verloren und dachtest, ich rette es noch!
[Kiki] Und ich wollt's auf dich schieben! Oh!
Okay! So, ich tu jetzt Mascarpone einfach in die Rührschüssel.
Wie gesagt, alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen natürlich unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Das ist eine ganz schöne Menge aber das ist natürlich auch ein XXL Riegel!
[Hamza] Leute jetzt nicht meckern, dass es zu viele Kalorien hat, ne?
[Kiki] Nee, also wegen Kalorien darf man hier gar nichts sagen!
[Hamza] Man sollte auch nicht den ganzen Riegel alleine essen, ne?
[Kiki] Zucker..
[Kiki] Eben!
[Hamza] Man soll's teilen!
Ja, dafür ist es da, damit man's teilt! So!
Sahne auch ganz kalt ausm Kühlschrank, Zucker hab ich eben schon hinzugegeben.
Was ich jetzt reingebe ist Vanilleextrakt.
Ja, ich weiß: Bei Kinder Pingui gibt's kein Vanilleextrakt!
[Kiki] Da ist..
[Hamza] Machen wir's bisschen schmackhaft, oder?
Genau, da ist nämlich Vanillin drin und statt Vanillin, also künstlicher Vanille -
ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung aber ich hab jetzt Vanilleextrakt.
Das schmeckt mir besser, das schmeckt intensiver und das gebe ich jetzt mit dazu.
Jetzt fange ich an, das zu rühren und gebe dann nach und nach Sahnefest mit dazu.
Erst langsam, dann immer schneller und dann dauert's wirklich auch nur 2 - 2½min.
Und das wollte ich euch auch noch sagen: Eine optionale Zutat und zwar Magermilchpulver.
Das gibt's mittlerweile in jedem gut sortierten Supermarkt, bei Kaufland kriegt ihr das safe 100%ig.
Und das ist optional. Wenn ihr das nicht habt oder nicht möchtet, dann lasst es einfach ersatzlos weg.
Ich persönlich finde, dass man dadurch nochmal diesen typischen Milchgeschmack bekommt.
Denn wie heißt es in der Werbung? Knackig-kühle Schokolade und 'ne Creme aus...?
[Hamza] Aus frischer Vollmilch!
[Kiki] Frischer Vollmilch!
Das ist jetzt keine frische Vollmilch aber so geschmacklich wird's dann einfach passen!
So die Creme ist jetzt fertig, die kommt ganz kurz an die Seite und wir machen jetzt die mittlere Schokoschicht.
Wichtig ist, dass die jetzt so ein bisschen weicher wird und nicht bricht beim Schneiden.
Dafür habe ich mir folgendes Rezept überlegt:
Ihr schnappt euch Zartbitterkuvertüre, schön fein hacken und jetzt habe ich hier ein Wasserbad.
Das hier ist Wasser. Das habe ich aufgekocht, jetzt habe ich den Herd wieder ausgeschaltet.
Und da kommt eine feuerfeste Schüssel obendrüber.
Was ihr auch direkt noch mit dazu geben könnt, denn sie muss sowieso schmelzen, ist die Butter.
So und das lasse ich jetzt kurz schmelzen, nehme das dann vom Herd
und rühre noch Schmand mit rein. Ihr könntet alternativ zu Schmand auch gerne Crème fraîche benutzen.
So, als nächstes teilt ihr euren Schokoboden einmal längs durch damit ihr 2 Böden erhaltet.
Für meine Form habe ich jetzt einfach denselben eckigen Backrahmen genommen, mit dem ich auch den Boden gebacken habe,
habe den klein eingestellt - die genauen Maße schreibe ich euch aber unten in die Videobeschreibung -
und weil mir noch 2cm gefehlt haben, habe ich einfach Pappe genommen, in Frischhaltefolie umwickelt und mir damit so ein bisschen Platz "weggenommen" quasi.
Und jetzt passt es einfach perfekt!
Der erste Boden ist schon drin, jetzt kommt die Hälfte unserer Milchcreme rein,
danach kommt die Schokoladencreme.
Und das Gute ist wirklich, dass wir bei der Schokocreme jetzt ein bisschen Zeit hatten, dass die so ein bisschen runterkühlen konnte
damit sie nicht zu warm ist für unsere Mascarpone-Sahne Creme.
So, das lasse ich jetzt aushärten und dann kommt die zweite Sahneschicht obendrauf.
Jetzt versiegeln wir die obere Schicht noch mit einer Mischung aus Zartbitterkuvertüre und Kokosfett.
Und jetzt kann die obere Schicht nämlich nicht austrocknen im Kühlschrank
denn die Kühlzeit beträgt mindestens 6h, sehr, sehr gerne aber auch über Nacht
damit eben alles schön fest wird und wir das dann rausholen können aus der Form.
Und dann fehlt eigentlich nur noch außen die Schokoladenhülle und dann sind wir auch schon fertig!
Ich würd' aber sagen wir sehen uns morgen wieder, denn es wird schon dunkel draußen! Es ist schon ein bisschen spät.
Ähm ja - bis morgen, tschüss!
Tag Numero 2!
Ich hab jetzt hier mein XXL Pingui gerade aus dem Kühlschrank geholt und geb das jetzt auf meine Servierplatte.
So!
Was ich auch schon gemacht habe, ist dass ich etwas Kuvertüre überm Wasserbad geschmolzen habe.
Ich hab noch Kokosfett dazugegeben damit man's einfach schön anschneiden kann, ohne dass es knackt und bricht.
So, und jetzt müssen wir das Ganze einmal lösen.
Genau für solche Momente gibt es natürlich nicht nur einen Backformlöser, sondern auch einen XXL Backformlöser!
Ihr wisst ja, dass es diesen hier schon ein bisschen länger gibt.
Das ist einfach dieser klassische Backformlöser für ganz normale Tortenringe, Backrahmen etc.
In dem Fall komme ich jetzt zwar hier mit dem normalen Backformlöser dran,
hier allerdings nicht! Ich war schon grad ein bisschen verzweifelt wenn ich ehrlich bin!
Ich hab gedacht: "Wie krieg ich das jetzt raus, ohne dass es mir reißt?" und dann ist mir das geniale Teil eingefallen!
Und da gehe ich jetzt einfach rein und löse das, ohne dass ich mir die ganze Creme wegreiße.
Das ist super wichtig weil sonst habt ihr kein schönes, gerades Ergebnis.
So! Der Vorteil ist natürlich, dass ich hier eine mega, mega dünne Klinge habe!
Falls ihr zuhause ein Messer habt, irgendein Utensil, das genauso dünn ist, dann nehmt das natürlich sehr, sehr gerne!
[Hamza] Das muss wirklich sehr, sehr schmal sein!
[Kiki] Es muss sehr, sehr dünn sein, genau!
[Kiki] Taste Teeest!
[Hamza] Willst du reden auch?
[Kiki] Äh... ich überlass dir das Reden Hamza!
[Hamza] Okay, was habe ich hier Leckeres?
[Kiki] Also das ist ja jetzt - das Rezept ist fertig, ne?
[Kiki] Das Endergebnis habt ihr gesehen und das Wichtigste in diesem Video ist deine Meinung!
[Hamza] Also ich muss sagen: Normalerweise wenn du Kuchen backst oder so, dann weiß ich nie, wie das am Ende aussieht, ne?
[Hamza] Aber in dem Fall wusste ich wie das aussieht, ne? Das sieht krass aus!
[Hamza] Ey Leute, das ist nicht normal! Das ist meine Hand, das ist heftig!
[Kiki] Krass!
[Hamza] Also zwei.. drei mal!
[Kiki] Also es ist wirklich -
[Hamza] Da fehlt sogar noch eins! Also eigentlich eher so, ne? Wahrscheinlich vier mal!
[Kiki] Es ist wirklich das größte Pingui auf der ganzen Welt!
[Hamza] Hey guck mal! Schau dir das mal an, wie oft das da reinpasst! Das ist unglaublich!
[Hamza] Es ist auf jeden Fall ein XXL Pingui, auf jeden Fall! Oh Kiki hat's schon angeschnitten für mich, yep!
[Hamza] Der geht gaaanz leicht runter aber ist nicht so schlimm Schatz!
[Hamza] Es sieht trotzdem toll aus!
[Kiki] Es ist selbstgemacht!
[Hamza] Ja, ist ja nicht schlimm! Ich mein ja bevor jemand was sagt! Aber -
[Kiki] Boah du bist ein harter Kritiker, ne?
[Hamza] Ja komm, ne Kiki? Also wenn schon, denn schon, ne?
[Hamza] Nein, es sieht aber heftig aus! Also da ist es sehr, sehr gerade! Das sieht heftig aus. Also besser - besser...
[Hamza] On point! That's on point! Also ich bin mal gespannt, wie es schmeckt!
[Hamza] So, ich probier das mal. Aber ich muss sagen: Das ist wahrscheinlich eine dicke Schicht jetzt, ne?
[Hamza] Obwohl nee, es geht! Nee, geht voll klar!
[Kiki] Hamza, versuch mal von allen Schichten auf deine Gabel zu nehmen, okay?
[Hamza] Alle?
[Kiki] Also die unteren wiederholen sich ja! Ich mein nur, dass du -
[Hamza] Dass ich wenigstens die mittleren noch bekomme, ne? Also so wahrscheinlich, ne?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] M-hm, m-hm!
[Hamza] Ja! Kiki: Geil, geil!
[Hamza] Es schmeckt nicht 1:1 gleich aber sehr, sehr nah!
[Hamza] Richtig geil! Ey allein diese mittlere Schicht, ne?
[Hamza] Das - also diese mittlere Zartbitterschicht, ne?
[Hamza] 1:1!
[Kiki] Danke!
[Hamza] Aber ich glaube es liegt auch daran, dass das alles viel dicker ist, dass das schwerer ist zu beurteilen.
[Hamza] Aber das hast du voll krass gut hinbekommen, wirklich!
[Hamza] Von der Optik bis hin zum Geschmack!
[Kiki] *lacht* Danke!
[Hamza] Ich sag's mal so: Ich hab dich immer schon geliebt und mit jedem Tag immer mehr!
[Hamza] Aber hier hast du nochmal 3 Schritte draufgelegt!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Das ist echt geil Leute! Mmmh! Ey diese mittlere Schicht, hammer!
[Hamza] Und die Creme! Ich finde man schmeckt auch ein bisschen dieses Magermilchpulver!
[Kiki] M-hm!
[Hamza] Ein bisschen schmeckt man das raus. Weil das ist ein bisschen anders als bei den andere Cremes normalerweise.
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Aber so - Ey Leute, macht's nach! Ich schwör's euch!
[Hamza] Macht's nach, das ist hammer geil! Leider geil!
[Hamza] Probier mal bitte! Ich mein's ernst! Du wirst selber überrascht sein wie lecker das schmeckt!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Ich guck nur in die Kamera, ich seh dich nicht!
[Kiki] Boah!
[Kiki] Boah, das schmeckt echt gut!
[Hamza] Geil, ne?
[Hamza] Diese Zartbitterschicht ist hammergeil, ne?
[Kiki] Das schmeckt echt gut, das schmeckt nicht so fettig!
[Kiki] Das schmeckt so -  das schmeckt leicht! Man mag's mir gar nicht glauben weil man sieht so ein XXL Pingui.
[Kiki] Aber es schmeckt leicht!
[Hamza] Ja!
Ich hab ja viele XXL Rezepte schon gemacht und an der Stelle: Wenn ihr noch ein XXL Rezept von mir sehen möchtet,
kommentiert unbedingt was ich als nächstes machen soll!
Dann danke ich euch für's Zusehen, wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag!
Abonniert meinen Kanal kostenlos, hinterlasst ein Like und dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten Rezept!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!
[Hamza] Alles meins! Meins, meins, meins, meins, meins!
*beide lachen*